is taking off the mothership tomorrow
and you know who's steering that ship
it's the godfather of funk george
clinton this is awesome i'm so excited
to see this yes so i caught up with him
ahead of his one nation under a groove
tour stop in the city that he says
sparkles from outer space i love that
[Music]
george clinton it is an honor to have
you on las vegas now
it's good to be here how you doing rocky
i'm doing well i'm doing well how are
you in sunny los angeles
i'm i'm i'm here chilling right in my
old hood you know right around uh sunset
in la cienega
you know from the early 70s or right on
through to the early 80s this was where
all of our office was at the hotel was
at
so much history in that area and you are
a part of it all over the last 50 years
of a pioneering music career so let's
just get into it we got a show coming up
and and you announced your retirement
back in 2018 and this was supposed to be
the farewell tour but you're probably
going
forget that do you know what when the
when the pandemic came down
you know we didn't get a chance to
finish that tour what i love is that the
tour is called one nation under groove
so what would if our nation was
underground what would it look like
everybody be on the same beat
you know everybody have that smile
together all their friends
come together whatever it is we all be
one
[Music]
you're bringing that energy to the amp
at craig ranch on august 13th what can
people expect from your show what's
going on what's on the lineup
it's gonna be wild i mean we we tell
everybody to bring two booties one booty
one booty ain't enough for this one
we're gonna be in the amphitheater you
know usually we have to be
really respectful when we come to vegas
because you know it's a lounge act or
something you know people are on a
vacation and they chilling with them
but they're gonna be outside are we
outside
they they come and they coming for it so
we gonna bring it how has vegas played a
role
in that
legendary career right about 59 or 60
when vegas started happening that became
the dream that everybody wanted to do
they either want to go to the copa or
vegas lounges those were the your
aspirations you've been around you still
got it um what is the key to longevity
you know
in this in this space in this music
industry funk is its own reward
you give up the funk
folks give it back and when they give us
the phone you know when they're in the
audience
looking like they want what they paid
for
we'll be up there all night if somebody
don't pull the plug on us you know what
i'm saying so that actually gives you
the the energy and the ambition to want
to keep going
you know it ain't ain't no thing
[Music]
oh
george clinton thank you
i know i know i just wanted to go hang
out with him in person george clinton
and parliament funkadelic one nation
under a groove tour that is august 13
tomorrow at the amp at craig ranch